I work in a Learning Center that's a
school baby onward
this past few weeks I've been having
there's just been I worked with special
ed kids and uh
you know it's
oh yeah
I know what you're talking about brother
I was in special ed baby
let's hear more it's it's a job it gets
stuff done but recently there's been a
kid named James he has autism and
uh recently he's been trying to
uh
sexually assault me
that adds up baby oh
yeah
I mean I feel like if somebody
I don't know how to say this
first of all a lot of people named James
have
you know
they're chismed out
and that's
you could draw a damn graph of that and
it would check out well look if people
have autism they're going to want to
[__] they want to get out that damn they
want to [__] burp that little nut
wand baby
you know
they I mean
sometimes you just I feel if you ever
just been so just
you just want to spray on something
so I can't even if I had autism I'd
if you know
if I had fully documented autism
I would be I'd spray on half the things
in town probably let's hear more
and you know I don't really care but
it's more frightening for the other
students yes
um
the thing is you know
I know they can't help it and stuff but
every time he does it he just has this
look in his eyes oh yeah this lustful
evil look they say if the devil's got
your nuts he's got your eyes because the
eyes are just the nuts of the face
so
yeah the feeling you have in your nuts
is always the feeling that you have in
your eyes
go punch somebody in the nuts
and look in their eyes
same pain baby
and yeah look it's tough man look first
of all I commend you for being out there
and being on the front lines of um
of special ed
you know
uh let's hear more
almost like he knows what he's doing and
if he knows that it's wrong and he'll be
you know he'll be running around I'll be
stop that James stop it James please
stop and you know he'll be helicopter in
it oh and it's just it's scary
and we're a little we're a little fright
for our safety
well hold on let's don't get crazy
let's you know
I mean you know you don't have to be
afraid for your safety though you gotta
you know you got a mentally unwell fella
just you know running around trying you
know
I mean he's probably in heat have you
thought about that
it's spring baby it's almost spring it's
gonna be spring in a few months
so you don't know what
you know and if somebody's autism they
might be off by a month or two and their
genetics easily
you can easily see that that's [__]
that's the DNA leap year homie if you
got autism
so
yeah dude it's springtime that Fella's
in heat
that's what you're getting there
James is in heat man
I get him a little bust post over in the
corner
get a little pair of uh
um
get you a half of a mannequin and put
some damn uh
uh Daisy Dukes on it that's what I would
do
and put that thing you know put a candle
or two in a closet and let them get in
there and pump on it
you know you have to have a plan
but if you're just yelling stop it James
and he's out there just you know
he's tugging on that little spunk
whisker that's stop it James it ain't
gonna help
you know you're not a damn crossing
guard brother
or
hit him with some Narcan brother
that'll shut anybody down
you know they don't like to put all the
different you know uses or whatever on
the thing but
if I got a you know somebody in my area
and they're over there splurging their
little uh that little splash Hammer
right in front of me I'll just damn hit
him with that Narcan baby
you know let the Lord sort them out
praise God babe let's hear a little bit
more and thank you for the call man I'm
sorry that you're having to deal with
some of this and I'm almost afraid of
some students because
we found it we found a collection of
uh almost like a booger collection but
it was
it was other people's pictures that he
took from under a stairwell
so
but we've been working on stuff I don't
know what to do with him well he might
be damn an artist brother you can't you
know it sounds like he's an artist
so don't condemn him for that
um you know I know they can't help it
but every time I every time I look into
the eyes he's just he's just painting
with that lustful um he'll smirk when he
does it too it's like he knows what he's
doing that's heat brother he's in heat
and that's somebody in heat and so I
think at that point you got to do prayer
you gotta you gotta consider Narcan but
I would do prayer first
and um
and yeah and look I'll just commend you
man for being there
and being there on the front lines of
autism
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one